le 4 août dernier la double explosion
qui frappe le port de beyrouth
anéanti 10% de la capitale libanaise
on
des immeubles et architecture historique
de la ville n'échappe pas à la
destruction causée par le drame
[Musique]
l'organisation des nations unies
l'unesco promet alors des efforts pour
sauver un héritage libanais à flot et 60
immeuble historique qui risque de
s'effondrer
l'un des plus grands dommages causés par
l'explosion se trouve dans le quartier
de game has est un district proche du
port de beyrouth
ici à 75 ans abdou fall ron est l'un des
propriétaires de ce quartier historique
selon lui aucune aide ne lui a été
proposé
excepté quelques volontaires et âme
charitable
mes ancêtres vivaient ici il y a deux
cents ans et elle appartient à notre
famille depuis tout ce temps
et quand l'explosion s'est produite
j'étais assis là avec ma femme ma fille
et mes deux petits-enfants
[Musique]
tous les escaliers étaient en marbre on
n'en fait plus des comme ça
ce bâtiment a été édifié avec un vrai
sens artistique
maintenant tout est informatisé sans âme
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais rien vu qui ressemble à
l'explosion du port nous avons été
témoins de guerre et d'effusion de sang
mais rien de semblable
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
même s'ils terminent leur enquête et
arrêtent des gens cela ne ramènera ni ma
maison ni notre histoire ce sont les
politiciens qui doivent être tenus pour
responsables de ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
nous avons construit ce pays et nous
allons le reconstruire
[Musique]